[Music]
just six days until Dancing with the
Stars is back Maxim Tamara Kosti is back
on the dance floor oh my goodness does
he have his hands full Cameron he does
because he's paired with every rose now
of course she is a vh1 talk show host
social media star they both have fiery
personnel
do they ever they do so does that mean
there's gonna be a little bit of trouble
while we were first to find out first
high five and what is your favorite
thing amber about being paired with max
he's fun he's silly but he's also very
professional he knows what he's doing
and that's really important so I kind of
just looked to him um and now we say yes
sir no sir
these two have hit it off but got into
some dancing hot water for posting some
top secret rehearsal video to social
media I died within seconds my phone
just blew off as I kept Jay can you just
not put this up after winning the mirror
ball with Meryl Davis for 2014 max
stepped away from competing I just don't
think that I have any more to give to
the show as a pro but now the
daddy-to-be is happy to be back with new
sort of like taking a break I feel like
I feel like I'm just having fun with
this you know as opposed to treating it
like a job and like this is a must you
know you have to do it the outspoken
amber broke the news to et she's now
sharing dating advice on the revamped
love line you can listen to the podcast
on play dot it call my show and I'm
there with open arms and this mom does
son Sebastian is giving max pointers on
parenting with fiance Peta Murgatroyd
she has a lot of advice I give him
advice on I just work I just bought PETA
um some just shea butter yesterday yes
no she does--she bought it up yeah she
just always a better deal singing I'm
like what is that that's some stuff
amber gave